Anika nice seeing you again pretty sweet
seeing you again
yes what a journey you've been on Wow
all right how are you feeling you're
coming out of the house you're in the
jury does it feel real yet is this is
this a dream or what's going on in your
head
I know it is crazy a dust you like a
dream like I would have preferred to be
in the house but I
like love everyone love seeing coming
back to all my other friends but yeah
it's been a crazy Journey
my bad I'm bad so let's talk a little
bit about your La your game in the last
couple weeks all right so
last week Ty kind of broke your heart a
bit he used The veto on Claudia when he
told you he wasn't going to what was
going through your mind this week when
he won HOH
yeah so he did lie to me and use the
pier again party and that did break my
like my trust because I genuinely for
once like the whole season did not trust
and did not trust them and the one time
I decided to trust him he breaks my like
breaks my trust but trades me and then
as soon as he won the HOH
um I was still okay with it because it's
only it was only four of us so I know it
all came I came up to like the comps so
who won the POV so I'm not too upset
like yeah Claudia did win fair and
square and then knowing that it was
going to be either me or Daniel C and I
also knew she had a closer relationship
with Daniel then myself so I don't know
you know what it's it's all fair I'm not
mad or upset about it on with anyone but
definitely not happy with time
so throughout the season you stuck very
close to Daniel C uh you probably said
he was your number one how did you feel
when Claudia did win that veto and you
knew that you'd be sitting beside your
number one on the Block
so not a great feeling and that was kind
of the last thing I wanted the season is
to be on the Vlog beside Daniel see
because I love him so much he has been
my number on from day one and in a game
set up like this it was odd for me to be
able to trust someone so much and I did
that I still do like I trust him so much
like we got each other's back like the
whole season
um so it was not a good feeling because
I knew it was going to be me or him um
and we really wanted to make it to the
top two so it did break my heart but
also I in my head I'm like okay if it's
not me going far I want him to go far
and win the show for me because he
deserves it so much
was there was there a glimmer of hope
that Claudia would evict Daniel over you
what was your in campaign points to
Claudia
um there was a very tiny glimmer of hope
that she might because
um I think coming to the top three
um I think com again is very important
because you need to when those comps
even make it to the third round kind of
thing so my selling point was um yeah
I'm not gonna come so far that you can
definitely beat me and then you can kind
of like decide at the end and the other
point was oh like
um I'm excited to know if she knew about
the crown and everything so I was kind
of excelling to her that oh I don't have
a good stand in the jury which I knew in
my head I do but to her I was selling
all I don't know where I stand with the
jury just so that also attempts her oh
like she doesn't have a good stance
maybe I will have a good chance of
winning beside her so those were the
brief points I did use but again like I
wasn't fighting that hard I kind of like
just let her decide
yeah do you think that the fact that
when you raise your weight she was your
target uh had any effect on her decision
this week
probably but but that's kind of that's
going to be done because she did put me
on the Block on the double so it was
kind of like we're even at that point so
I think it all came down to her
relationship with Daniel was a lot like
she was a lot closer to Daniel than
myself because they started like I guess
game talks and game planning way before
I started getting close to the girls so
gotcha got you
um so first of all congratulations
making final four that's a that's a big
accomplishment not many people can say
that they made the final four what what
game move would you like to be
remembered for in BBK 11
yeah for sure so my game move is
definitely
everyone knows that I'm not like a
mastermind but then for me definitely a
social game was my game I created
Alliance as I went but sticking loyal to
most of it not all but then definitely
the crime was something I definitely was
loyalty I was loyal to Daniel and my
like a line so I think for me the social
game uh and then creating alliances as I
went but also staying true to the lines
that I created had like fighting for
people that I I thought like I I don't
know I connected with I was working with
I stood for them fought for them and
yeah that's kind of what I want to be
remembered for
well give yourself some credit because
you did do that under 20 seconds you
want an HOH so hey hey come Beast
I'll take that
yeah speaking of the crown and you're
Alliance what what was it about the
crown members that Drew you all together
yeah
um I think what made us closer was like
like is it coming oh let's work together
it was more our situations uh brought us
together which made it stronger well for
most people not for everyone which we'll
get to that later but yeah I think I'm
seeing the dedication that people like
Jonathan hope had for the for the for
the alliance like even me and Dennis I
knew where I stood when I see how much
Jonathan and hope were putting in like
effort and like really like for them it
was a lot more than not just a regular
lens and seeing that really made me feel
like okay this is genuinely an alliance
that I want to work with and go far so I
think that's what made us stronger is
our circumstances brought us together
and now Daniel C is the only crowd
member left in the game what do you
think was ultimately the demise of the
crown what was the turning point where
your the alliance really started to
break apart
um to be honest it was more like the
situation like the confidence like let's
say
um the first one was Jonathan star was
actually winning the
um POV so it I I think it all happened
um no one has to be blamed for how it
all happened but kind of like how it all
like okay her winning the con you're
saving Renee and then Jonathan going up
beside her when there was like two two
Crown members even the next week there
was like so there was like it just
happened that there was like always two
grand members for the past few weeks
um so the situations kind of work on the
comps played a big role the pov's played
a big role
um and also Tai I think Tai was a big
big reason for the Crown's downfall and
yeah don't like that guy okay
all right listen Anika you have been in
the HOH room you've been on the Block
you survived a double you survived the
Fatal Feast you've been up and down but
what moment are you most proud of in
this game
oh god um the moment that I am most
proud of
um oh it's hard to pick up so many you
know what I think I'm gonna say my HOH
because yes like it was a quick win but
Aaron just failed and that week was so
special because I know I've top five was
so important for me to make it to top
four wanted like and then that was my
birthday week like um even though yes I
did it would have been better with my
other Crown members but I think that was
like a very big moment for me when I did
want to come because I I needed to prove
when I come to prove to myself that okay
I'm not just here to play social game
and I can win comps as well so I was I
think a big highlight moment for me yeah
what would you say this game taught you
about yourself because we spoke before
we went in the house he told me you
weren't too well versed in this big
brother world you're kind of just going
in blind so when has this game really
talk taught you about yourself
um yeah like I literally came in blind I
didn't even know what slop was like that
that's how much I knew
um but I think um for me what what the
game taught me is how strong I am and um
emotionally and everything is when it
when the time came for decision making I
can set aside my emotions strength think
on me with my brain like game wise and
also like I think how like how I fought
for my friend to people that I genuinely
like and Trust I'm willing to fight for
you even if like like you're I will
support your decision even if that's not
the best game decision for myself like
being supportive of other people and yes
because situations will happen you will
need to change your game plan your game
move but staying true to who I am being
honest to people and strong like just
staying strong throughout the whole
there was lots of ups and downs but I
kept my head straight so kept focusing
on the game
um so I think yeah a lot I learned Lots
about myself awesome
all right so you're out of the house but
you're still in the game you have a big
decision to make coming up what are you
looking for in a winner someone to
represent your season is it someone that
played socially strategically can't
Beast well-rounded what are you looking
for
um how do you how do they get Anika's
vote yeah yeah so for me
um I want someone to win who who's game
gameplay I can align with I can um and
like I don't know just like more like
myself so I play the social honest and
social game I'm not a mastermind like I
didn't want I didn't come here to lie to
people make to see people some people
play that and rightfully so but for
myself I want to see a winner who
genuinely played an honest game had a
great social game yes Palm gwinds are
important but it starts on the NLB all
so I think someone who played from a
genuine heart they were themselves had a
great social game and of course some
comp wins here and there but I think
that's what I'm gonna be voting for is
someone who played a genuinely honest
gay men were themselves
awesome yeah well it is a big decision
you will be uh changing someone's life
so don't take it lightly and it was so
nice to talk to you enjoy the rest of
your time in jury congratulations on the
season and we'll see you on finale night
perfect take care all right enjoy